yacht au monde si aujourd'hui on se
retrouve le screamer audio on se
retrouve sur ce trade la peinture est
actuellement le but du jeu est de sauver
cette femme qui fait parfois la grimace
d'ailleurs je sais pas si j'ai envie de
la sauver c'est parti alors qu'est-ce
qu'on ago ok mais à formerie commence
ok johnston a nommés au mérite à m allez
on tu as poneys de mon gars on est plus
malin que toi ah mais non ok mais du
marché que les bras comme ça quoi oui
oui j'arrive
oui je vais acheter une baguette un
méchant que la clé c'est un gros piège
quoi cl oui oh c'est quoi ça me gave
d'ail 3 watts
je veux pas esquivé messi mais douchez
mars et elle ne m'a pas touché pièces
homme et non mais attends les missiles
de il est arrivé comme ça et au québec
n'y a pas d'explication rationnelle ça
va lui qu'à la princesse est à moi mais
tu allais se pousse quoi il se trappe
donc la princesse me dis que c'est un
piège d'accord donc je sais pas comment
je suis en vie dans ce cas c'est un
piège pour le coup ah mais non mais non
mais la belle musique
ça que je suis super mal ça suffit non
voyage j'ai cru que non il se trame
mélange talent de la [ __ ] ne me
stresse si je passe pas sur la trace sur
le levier et que je roche et je me
prends les pics comme une grosse mer
puis moins 400 met d'accord avec un
recul moins 4 semaines un peu comme ça
quoi ce que je sais peut-être bordel nom
ne peut dépasser les questions souple
est à mon avis qui on va là dessus il ya
une autre case activer voilà en
maintenant c'est grâce à toi tout cela
mais pas du tout bête fallait que je
remercie quelqu'un ose pas dessus et
voilà la blague nul bah oui d'où fuient
- six ans mais ça ou 6 4 6 1 depuis
guarbecque qu'à moitié sont cuits il est
pas là carrément non mais non mesdames
mois cette baisse est le seul espace ce
à quoi on me nomme si ce n'est qu'un
chat coup ça veut dire qu'il est
magicien réussie du magicien sauvetage
peut rien tout ce qui fait super tout ce
que ça veut dire qu'il peut finir ce jeu
saura plus tard mais bordel de alors là
falloir trouver le bon endroit mais non
mais quand ses quatre enfants louis
magnifique magnifique cassions nul à
home a princess d'amour what men on a
trois grilles fermées doué sur le dpm me
transperce quoi je te vois jeu d'acteur
impuissance mines qu'ils a molli lui
secondes voilà tu mais c'est impossible
je crois avoir compris je ne faut que je
défende en fait d'accord faut que tire
sur le réveil barret d'étape français
pour ça tous les matins d'ailleurs win
ah j'aime ce pouce non comme me touche
autres apps vraiment en voile a annoncé
quoi ça aux dates un opus elle a rendu
heureux quoi ces journées elle été
refaite hommes et non mais qu'est ce
qu'elle faisait là elle s est carrément
évadés des niveaux d'avant quoi un plat
ça c'est fait onana tu caches quoi cette
fois un gun une batte de baseball
bonjour momo la battant l esprit dire
maman a toujours dit que je n'étais pas
un gros hockey est-ce que je peux juste
avoir le temps de jouer éventuellement
hockey non mais attends me mets et qu'on
la plaquette 1
non là il ya un cube cacher je suis sûr
et certain
non à domicile crottes qui de l'espace
ilyes le saut le saut non j'allais sur
la tête de la princesse pour la sauver
va ce point d'orgue à sion 3 2 fois ok
alors attention la plus grosse connerie
de la planète dans trois ans c'est parti
on y arrive
oh mais c'est quoi ça mais non mais
attends un pédo 4 qui passe comme ça
maintenant faut que je te nomme quoi
c'est un vieux blocs caché chez paou là
haut
la chance oui ma princesse je t'aime
prends les armes et ne revient jamais en
arrière ça marche
d'accord ok une sorte de unicorn de 20
mètres de haut qui m'a défoncé est-ce
qu'il ya choix qui est bon never fall
bac si je reviens en arrière
ah ah ah ah ah ah oui ma princess
d'amour gotha watts dont quelques uns
s'étaient cachés aux princesses elle a
juste carrément l'ère de la vraie
princesse quoi mexes et un travesti pro
quoi bon je fais comment du coup hop par
là haut au true love home and away we go
mais tu as joué de bouteilles d'eau jeux
bretons je décède quang et c'est que ça
battant avec quoi ils vont passer à
travers ou salés retient d'accord donc
ça c'est non merci
moi je veux juste un petit temps fort au
milieu de mes deux papas chaque homme
savent non je peux leur taper dessus la
non tant la puissance n'est pas mme asha
me fait juste faire non et voilà je suis
libre vous êtes le premier à passer le
niveau 2 3 mais ce niveau n'est pas
terminée merci d'avoir joué aux deux
journées au [ __ ] y'a un truc à faire
le belge peut pas violer le note
ma princesse mais que faisais-tu des as
ce panneau attarde
yes alors hein tu fais quoi face au mur
maintenant tu veux un cours de
claquettes c'est ça ça fait plaisir
par contre les cours de claquettes ces
cours particuliers ok pas plus tard
voilà on ne sait pas qu'il fallait
monter sur le missile et je suis sûr
qu'il fallait monter dessus
voilà au [ __ ] de fours de merde
non non alors missiles je t'attends quoi
il ya un piège là on va direct aller
vers la princesse huawei ce temps passé
par là comme ça hein c'est quoi ce
délire encore attendre mais là c'est
fire mais non mais ça fait rire tout on
fire c'est carole ardak le pea pourquoi
ils veulent du mal alors je fais partie
des leurs [ __ ] ah bah moi je suis pas
un rond parfait je suis un ovale bah
voila voila raciste c'est tout [ __ ] de
raciste yes fallait juste et toucher à
temps mais c'est quoi ça le ridja qui me
dit pas quoi faire princesse parce que
sans moi tu serais jy encore au cachot
oh mais je pensais qu'on était ami non
mais non merci ça met la pression quand
ça casse derrière s'il vous plaît rien
qu'une fois
laissez moi sortir pour un jeu vidéo oui
oui la plateforme mais non mais non mais
non non non
ça c'est le tube de l'été 2000 24,1 au
même les mecs a fallu toucher je pense
après avoir joué un jeu tu touche
absolument à tous quoi allez ça va ça si
quelqu'un a la solution
je suis tout ouïe plus sans déconner
qu'est-ce qu'on est supposé faire quand
une bande de gens qui copient le
mouvement parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
personnalité en plus de ça nous tue ce
lancer sauter banon alors ça il fallait
avant moi qui en ait un qui soit
meilleure pour deux peuples à aller mon
gars attachant a annoncé ce faut faire
j'ai compris c'est pas ça hop et hop là
ça c'est pas prévu
moi j'en peux plus mais est ce elle n'en
peuvent plus mon t-shirt un peu plus
fameux qe2 va quoi mais non mes mecs
mais non mais non mais oh non [ __ ] pas
non non non non non non non non non je
refuse d'affronter et sont trop nombreux
ils sont trop forts
non mais [ __ ] le levier se mettre en
confiance son corps offert doit voir un
cube en fait le gros fake aux médias
mais qui si c'est un suicide là on vient
d'assister un gros sucide au fait juste
l'activé plein de fois princesse tu sors
pas d'épée bienvenue à la maison trouve
la bonne clé pour ouvrir la porte
alors dire moi je m'en fous des clés je
veux juste voir un truc d'accord ça me
tue ça marche voilà voilà voilà ça j'en
étais sûr
mais ouais tout à l'heure elle sent une
épée pour me poignarder là il suffit
juste de cassé une porte est pas foutu
de le faire quoi mais je viens d'essayer
toutes les clés pour quoi paribas non
mais j'ai juste tout essayé quoi y'a pas
moyen à les soussous chapeau du mec la
clé comment ça se passe les magiciens il
peut faire apparaître la bonne clé ou
faire disparaître la porte
faire disparaître cette tablette pour
que j'arrête de jouer à ce jeu où je
perds du temps de la fatigue de
l'énergie et tout ça pour rien je vais
regarder un solution jusque là j'en ai
marre c'est pire ce que oui il faut
retirer la peau car tu retournes le menu
principal retour de vue là il ya la clé
au uk elles font la proie de rouffach
start et revenir tôt jeudi vous mais
depuis quand on peut deviner ça tout
seul non mais là je puisse pas faire le
groupe housse pour aller vous aussi
compliqué juste pas possible quoi non
j'ai dit non j'ai dit non
j'ai dit non arrêté et vous la légion
c'est déjà fin de cette petite vidéo sur
strange adventures sur tablette
honnêtement je suis 2g pas le courage de
finir le jeu
le dernier niveau m'a juste sidéré si
les arrêts j'espère ça vous aura plu si
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas mais la vidéo
ça fera vraiment plaisir on se retrouve
très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo de
chant tout le monde
pis
il
ted
m